hi my name is rama akiraju i'm an ibm
fellow and cto for aifs at ibm
today i want to talk about the
opportunity for ai in optimizing it
operations
the vision of
self-healing self-monitoring
and self-managing i.t systems which was
primarily the vision of autonomic
computing
was not realizable to the extent that we
had wanted to up until now
primarily because we didn't have
all of the
main ingredients that we need to make
that happen which include the kind of
compute which include the advanced
algorithms to process
natural language data of structured and
semi-structured and unstructured data
so while some progress has been made on
this front i would say a lot was left on
the table
but thanks to the advancements in
cloud computing in ai and in machine
learning specifically and the recent
advancements in natural language
processing
now make it possible for us to
really put ai to use to optimize it
operations
so today i want to talk about what that
opportunity is and what we are doing at
ibm
and in general for the industry and the
community what the what they can do and
what the opportunities
so if you look at uh
site reliability engineers or it
operations administrators who are the
main
persona or people who are responsible
for managing these i.t applications to
keep them up and running highly
available reliable and
highly scalable and such in in
production environments
oh i don't know why it's doing that in
we see that they are constantly playing
catch-up psycho game that is a problem
occurs in production and they are woken
up at 3 a.m in the morning and they have
to go
you know looking for where the problem
has been debug it diagnose it quickly
apply some resolution action
and
and then figure out what the actual
cause of the problem is and send it over
to the development team or they
themselves have to get to it but before
they can get to it and address some of
the root causes another production
problem happens and they're on it again
the same cycle repeats so they we have
to help
the i.t operations administrators and
the cios
break out of this cycle to to get from
reactive incident management to
predictive and proactive so that we can
help avoid these issues from happening
in the first place but of course
whenever there is a
a problem
your house is on fire you need to be
able to put it out first right it
doesn't help to go you know try to build
a swimming pool at that time so we need
to still provide
enough automation and capabilities to
set reliability engineers to
address the problem at hand when in real
time when a production problem occurs
and still be able to
help them predict and avoid them in the
future so we see
the opportunity for aips is to
to really infuse ai throughout the
cycles of
reactive you could also say real time
predictive and proactive in each one of
these phases
we can
envision opportunities for ai where ai
may start out
by being
an assistant a guide a helper to a human
and human is actively driving the main
decision-making and such all the way to
the system
taking the lead and automating as much
of it as as uh as it can while keeping
human in the loop so our vision is for
the self-healing self-managed self
um
monitoring applications like dartmouth
vision of autonomic computing we really
want to build enough automation so that
the systems are capable of doing that
but it's going to be a journey
so to motivate i want to first present
this example where let's say
in an environment in an i.t operations
environment all kinds of things are
happening at any given point in time and
if you have let's say
some kind of application performance
monitoring type of application installed
you're constantly monitoring the health
of your applications by looking at the
metrics by looking at
the application logs and whatnot
so
typically in an environment and
any number of things could be happening
some um
your memory consumption could certainly
go down because there is a garbage uh
um cleaning um you know
activity that just happened garbage
collection one or that
a particular shopping applications
shopping cart is not accessible
um and the system is down so you're
getting all these types of events
some are actionable
and some require action some are some
don't require action for example the
garbage collection because of which
memory certain memory you know
usage drop
doesn't really require an action so it's
an event that can go into into a log but
you don't have to wake up in it
operations administrator at three three
a.m in the morning for that
whereas if uh you know the shopping cart
of a particular retail application is
down you do want to notify the person
but then
you know just mentioning that you know a
shopping cart application is down in
itself is not useful you want to collect
more information you know maybe it
actually went down
because their server caught fire
why did the server catch fire maybe
because the fan was not working
and so
individually all of these systems if you
are monitoring them they may be sending
alerts
say fan failure or that server failure
or this particular shopping cart failure
now the question is
do you send all of these
different kinds of alerts events to the
user
and bother the user
let them figure out whether they're all
related to the same incident that is
happening at that point in time or can
we do better right there is an
opportunity for ai where it can
correlate
all of these alerts based on the
signatures in them which could be
mentioned of the ip addresses mentions
of the particular server service
component
and if you have access to the
application topology it could be about
how they are all related to one another
and therefore
you correlate them and say okay alert a
b and c came
but they are all related to
one another based on the topological
relationship
and now i see that together you know all
of these alerts really are a group and
they
need to be promoted as an incident to be
notified
uh because you know the actual business
application that touches the
end customers
is getting affected because of it like
in this particular case it's the
customer's
application and the shopping cart is not
accessible okay so you create an
incident ticket at that point and
you know
notify
the it operations administrator but then
is that it you know what are they going
to do
how should they bring it up
immediately so maybe you know the system
can even provide a recommendation and
we'll get to how it can provide those
recommendations in just a bit but if it
can even provide a recommendation and
say
well you know this application
has shopping cart is down immediately
forward this this set of requests coming
to the redundant server okay
so that will fix the problem
that's a quick repair
but really the to address the root cause
what you have to do you should procure a
new server
and uh
ensure that the new server is set up
properly and then divert traffic
accordingly again so that would be the
long term resolution
so the system is able to provide that
resolution and not just stop there
but go ahead and automatically run
the scripts corresponding scripts or run
books as they may call them
to read out the shopping cart
application to the redundant server and
to automatically create
a provisioning request for a new server
how about that so that is taking action
proactively and helping an i.t
operations administrator and freeing up
their time
from addressing these problems so that's
the kind of examples that we are talking
about so what exactly what are the
metrics that we are trying to improve as
part of this it operations management we
are talking about reducing the mean time
it takes to diagnose an incident detect
isolate
fix them and verify that the problem is
not repeating
so the main times that are measured for
each one of these things if we are able
to reduce it that eventually boils up to
you the the particular company who is
doing the monitoring and using ai ops
application would be able to better
serve their customers with high
availability high reliability and as a
result
they're able to honor
or even exceed the service level
agreements and objectives that they are
setting for themselves so that is the
goal
but better still what we want to be able
to do is
not to just do the reactive
not stop there but be able to really get
to the source of the problem
and proactively avoid it from happening
so one of the things that the
opportunities that we see here is
why is the following why do problems
occur in production
typically problems occur in production
because of some changes that are made
either to the application
or that the software
development process has gone through
certain changes in terms of new feature
getting added new
capability or bug
being
addressed and that change now got
deployed so if you look at the software
development process right from build to
and from design to to code test bill
code build test
then deploy the applications and finally
monitor them
if all we are doing is with application
performance monitoring type of systems
monitoring the health of applications
the best that you can do is when health
is going bad you can you know
and then certain metrics are going
haywire
you can do incident management but if
you want your you know you don't even
want those metrics to be going haywire
in the first place the best way to do it
is to catch problems before they occur
you know the analogy that i often like
to give is
exactly like human health right if you
want to avoid
um you know some of these lifestyle type
of problems like blood pressure or
diabetes and those sort of things you
really want to
have good you know eating habits good
sleeping habits good exercise habits and
that's the best way to prevent and
proactively avoid those problems
the idea here is the same so you get
into
the software development life cycle and
examine each of the artifacts as and
when they're getting produced such as
um the build the code changes the test
coverage
and the deployment
changes that are coming in the pull
requests the change requests and so on
and be able to if you're able to
proactively predict the risk associated
with those and say hey this particular
change that you have made at this point
in time is a highly risky one because in
the past similar type of incidents have
results similar type of changes have
resulted in incidents in production and
here is a specific place where you may
want to make a change in order to really
improve the quality of this change
so that the likelihood of this causing
any problem in production is low
how cool would that be so that is the
the nirvana we want to get to with
proactive issue avoidance so the idea is
that at every step of the way in the
software development lifecycle you put
in checks and gates so the gates are the
risk predictions
and you say
you know institute a workflow process
where if the risk is higher than a
certain threshold don't even promote
that activity to production
so
what are if we look at both reactive
predictive and proactive what are the
various analytics that we can do so in
the motivating example i i had
shown
um a set of steps that are happening
that is
somebody is set
observing and generating those events
the events being
the shopping cart is down or that
certain memory usage has dropped
so that's about observing the metrics
but from them from from those metrics to
general being able to generate alerts
you need some kind of an anomaly
prediction
so the opportunity here is you know
first you can think of observing
observing metrics logs
um from the production environment and
being able to do anomaly detection from
them then
you know grouping that you know when a
server failure
a fan failure and a shopping cart
failure is coming and
i had shown in the example how they need
to be grouped because you don't want to
bother
an i.t operations administrator with
each one of them individually but really
tell
a coherent story that this incident is
happening and multiple
alerts are getting raised because of it
because multiple systems are
that are dependent on it and then
whichever is the root cause of the issue
are all raising alerts too right so that
is grouping them all to reduce noise
event grouping
and there is a lot of opportunity for
different analytics in doing that but
let's let me first go through it and
then
given them on a short amount of time
i'll very briefly touch upon what are
the ai aspects of it
event grouping then identifying where
the actual cause might be what might
have caused the probable cause in the
chart that i had shown earlier you know
the probable cause in in the particular
case is
actually the fan failure the fan failure
is the root cause for the problem
because the fan failed server caught
fire because the server part buyer um
the shopping cart application that's
running on it went down right
uh so being able to identify that what
exactly caused the fault is very
important and you know there is a lot
that can be done there with regards to
capturing the the topology of the
applications and really figuring out
based on the relationships and the
directionality of the relationships what
might have caused the problem in the
first place then understanding the
impact i'm talking about the first
column right now in the reactive i
covered log and metric anomaly detection
event grouping fault localization
then blast radius what are all the
components that are getting affected as
a result of it
and
so once you do all of the diagnosis then
it's about okay how do i solve the
problem again in the example that i had
given i said well the recommendation is
to reroute um this particular shopping
cart requests to the redundant server
how would the system automatically come
up with such a request if it hadn't
either been manually you know a mapping
for each type of a problem has already
been created and you're doing the lookup
or that you have a knowledge of the
previous incident tickets and the
actions that were taken as part of those
previous insulin tickets and you are
able to now match the symptoms of the
the problem with what the known set of
issues in the incident taken prior
incident ticket records and extract the
actions that were taking taken and
provide that as a recommendation right
that would be
for some things maybe you would have a
simple mapping but for many things you
may not
um in such case really doing that
mapping is really important again here i
go back to the analogy of health because
um
that's really very appropriate here if
you go to a doctor's office you know
doctor listens to your
different symptoms you know say you have
runny nose you have cough you have fever
your chills
the doctor maps it to a known
problem that
he has
cured for other patients and immediately
says okay well if it's flu just you know
take rest if it is a bacterial you know
prescribe this particular
antibiotics um you know right
how does the doctor come up with it
because the doctor has done it enough
times and knows i mean here for an i.t
operations administrator because we are
trying to free up his time
while a human may be able to do it but
not every
individual at different levels of skill
sets may be able to immediately come up
with a resolution so we want to really
be that brain uh which is able to
capture that knowledge and is able to
quickly retrieve from within that
knowledge base as to what might be the
relevant recommendation here and
um you know provide the next action
recommendation now in the predictive
analytics it's about log metric
prediction you know before and
particular you know metric is going down
you see the trend of it and say hey here
is you know this you know memory usage
is steadily going up it's not yet
um above the thresholds therefore no
alert is getting raised yet
but i'm seeing it the pattern is
consistent and it's growing and it's
going to very quickly reach its limits
and before that a bad thing happen why
don't you happens why don't you yourself
actively take action you know predict it
right so that's the prediction part of
it
you can predict the severity of an
incident that might occur as a result of
it ahead of time
um and
predict what might be the root cause for
it and so on right so there are a bunch
of things that you can do in the
predictive category proactive one is
where i talked about where you really
look at the software development life
cycle shift left and the dev ops life
cycle if you will and um
predict the risk associated with
deployment changes with test coverage
based on that
the test quality and the build um and
the code
changes and the vulnerabilities and and
catch those problems early on so that
you can avoid those issues from
happening so there are different kinds
of analytics that are possible
so if you put it all together into a
system this is how it may look like you
know you are constantly observing in
real time logs tickets metrics topology
and those sort of things and in the
software development life cycle you are
looking at the heat issues
um the pull requests and the deployment
requests change requests and those sort
of things um but you have a bunch of
anomaly predictors detectors that are
running
and as they are getting uh they're
generating alerts events even groups
are being formed our alert grouping is
getting done and the actual problem is
being identified isolated and the
diagnosis is being done then on the
right hand side most part of it you will
see you tap into your prior knowledge
and to get the similar incidence and
predict and actually suggest
or better yet run those automations so
that you can resolve the problems and in
the predictive and proactive cases you
do change risk prediction types of
algorithms now what might be the
algorithms that we implement i know
i won't be able to cover them in depth
but i will just mention them
uh for anomaly prediction and detection
depending on the type of data if it is
metrics you can do a lot of time series
algorithms if it is logs
logs are unstructured data therefore you
have to really do quite a bit of uh
feature
feature preparation that is process the
logs uh by parsing them and log parsing
is a very interesting problem in itself
where you have to deal with
um different kinds of
extracting entities like date times and
host names and
uh
you know all kinds of um
strange formats that the data may come
in and really be able to extract
features and you can try convert those
tokenized features into word embeddings
to convert them into more structured
features which you can then process
through different kinds of time series
algorithms and such so we've uh
uh
explain
we've been
i would say successful at doing that
with logs um
in
doing the anomaly prediction from logs
then for event grouping and entity
linking and correlation and such
you can employ techniques such as
temporal grouping spatial grouping
association rule mining and such and for
fault localization and blast radius you
can look at uh graph traversal
and
you know graph theory based algorithms
to better understand the directionality
and what might have caused the problem
and for incident similarity you can map
it to information retrieval problem
where you're looking at prior tickets
incidents
from the prior ticket incident of the
database and matching the symptoms and
doing a lot of natural language
processing to extract summary phrases
that might be indicative of the actions
so you really have to look at action and
entity phrase extraction and sequencing
them likely to create
a sequence of actions so there is a lot
of nlp
time series algorithms machine learning
algorithms that
we can bring together to address this
problem um and not to forget the user
involvement in all of this don't let's
not for assume that even for a minute
that
the system can fully automate everything
we are not there yet users play a
critical role in the whole process um
keeping human in the loop to give
feedback to the system at various points
in the predictions that the system is
making and the recommendations the
system is making and taking that
feedback
incorporating that back into the system
and continuously learning and improving
the systems is critical to this building
successful
real useful real-world applications um
and finally i would conclude by saying
that
you know as with any ai infused
application
there are going to be
um
it's going to be a journey there are
going to be issues related to
bringing people up to speed uh
challenges in data preparation address
addressing the time to value
how much time does it take to train the
models how much data do you need versus
can you do something quickly
how much infrastructure do you need to
train these models and what skills do
people need to really manage these and
maintain these models these are all
non-trivial considerations that have to
be paid careful attention to
they're not specific to ai ups alone
they're specific to any ai application
that's being built in production and
being deployed
but
that would apply just the same to ai ups
as well so i would conclude by saying
that
that there is a tremendous opportunity
for ai to significantly optimize and
transform it operations management and i
hope i have given a quick view into what
those areas are namely i talked about
reactive predictive and proactive
[Music]
phases in doing it operations management
to get to that final vision of
achieving autonomic computing where you
have self-managing self-healing
self-monitoring applications
thank you
you